this is a majestic vulture and it's kind
is in serious trouble
but this 3d printed egg could help save
it yeah alright it doesn't look like
much but it's packed with sensors that
may unravel the mysteries of incubation
and help save endangered species you see
incubating an egg isn't just about
sitting on it the bird actually rolls
the thing around and keeps its
temperature and humidity just right with
the electronic vulture egg researchers
can better understand those ideal
conditions a good as a baby monitor for
birds and the scientists need that data
bad because vultures are in serious
trouble especially in Africa where they
fall victim to man-made poisons to save
them researchers need to breed vultures
in captivity and to replicate those
nests in a controlled environment but
this electronic egg isn't just about
saving vultures it's part of a
revolution in data-driven wildlife
conservation today researchers are using
drones to count populations of birds and
satellites track movements of bigger
animals like elephants it's the
beginning of a massive monitoring
network that will help scientists keep
tabs on the natural world so which came
first the global network of conservation
sensors or the egg
that be the egg a humble little
electronic egg